was ist ein ferrari fährt ja servus und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
timo jakits das wie immer geht es heute
darum dass ich woanders wollen
rundenspiele dabei die lustigsten kids
für euch rauszuhören zusammen schneidet
und euch in diesem video zeige das beste
kommt wie immer so gegen ende ihr wisst
wie bisher schon in dem laden
ich habe wieder auf twitter bescheid
gegeben und ich habe noch mal explizit
darum gebeten dass keine eta dpv psd
kids ins video kommen das heißt nicht
nur schwert und eine sondern tatsächlich
lustige kids alle leute stellen sich für
mich rein aber hey mach es unser großes
aufheben ich habe gar nichts auf doch
taschentücher trotzdem jetzt runde eins
und hier montiert das hält mich sehr fit
bleiben wir haben hier eines
professionell
wir haben eine riesen portion haben es
sehr sehr vieles creepers ponor und die
wm jetzt an aktive nicht zu scholle
durchzulaufen
okay aber bisher was wir sitzen ja sogar
da oben flugzeug da oben da da ist ein
ufo keine ahnung schäfer nach oben an
die kraft von ihnen das war alter ließen
sich ab gehen jetzt jetzt müssen wir ab
gehen ja ganz ehrlich und er brennt oder
brennt und brennt und es ist seine milch
und er brennt nicht mehr und er
verschwindet eine poison porsche und er
brennt noch mal
jetzt geht's ab mit seinem mac os x
laufen
jetzt muss man laufen er wird versuchen
auch seine pausen einzusetzen gegen uns
und er geht da und pippa strategie hat
nicht funktioniert aber das ist guck mal
hier leute richtig nein es geht wenn man
die fuldaer arrows vollkommen
unnatürlich man kann nichts machen
eine stoffel ich weiß auch nicht wo für
vielleicht ein bisschen abzubauen
mal klappt natürlich aber es ist doch
nichts ab vor allem haben wir 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 wölfe die wir jetzt alle schön mit
knochen zähnen können bis die uns lieben
er brauchte mussten überzeugt werden alt
richtig gieriger sagt ob acer die wollen
so viel knochen und jetzt machen wir
einfach nur hunde schlacht wie geil ist
das denn schöne idee man richtig coole
ideen jetzt greift ihr einfach dinge an
los
und die wölfe kämpfen gegen wölfe ich
musste für seinen reifen weg laufen
nein helft mir
34 jahren den sagt greift ihn an wölfe
committee hätte trüben
wisst ihr was ich hätte mein wölfen ich
lasse sie nicht dasitzen ich bin bei
euch leute kommen ich hatte das gefühl
man will sich damit nicht töten können
weil einfach wie sieht's aus
ich halte er richtig viele weltweit alle
vorteile von meinen wölfen abgemurkst
habe ich gefühlt viel von seinen noch
leben und meine wunden schaufel ist
kaputt okay das wird eine richtig war
dass es gibt noch welche von mir das war
nicht mein letzter übrigens ist auch
egal ob man mit der schaufel steht damit
der hand überhaupt ja formal weil ich
glaube ich dass sie wurden schon mehr
als einen punkt gemacht haben und jetzt
ein richtig viele von meinen wölfen da
wie jetzt geht's ab jetzt geht es an den
kragen
das war's das war es einfach klasse es
gibt für mit filmhits gibt wolfgang
virginia wolf hat keinen es geht gemacht
man verliert hunger stirbt
ich leg mich mit dem knochen wie
verzweifelt ist der wahl jetzt leben nur
noch meine wölfe kann das sein
ja ich weiß nicht wo ich hergekommen
sind aber sie leben jetzt könnt ihr ihn
tötet ihn tötet oder es dauern
wunderbar jungs sehr gut dafür könnte
der iceman leute das sieht nach dem lg
pad aus aber hier eine denkbar
ungünstige map dafür egal wer ist der
bahnhof mit dem virtual hier und da
unten kann man auch nicht so gut passen
weil ich hier ist bisschen gras das
ebenso aber auf jeden fall jemals hoch
ich hoffe den falschen an gemacht so
ready steady ok countdown 321 und co
es hat funktioniert wunderbar und bei
ihm auch gut essen ist falsch an wir
müssen natürlich mal hier den oppenauer
man das war nicht absichtlich
wir müssen erst noch der fall schaden an
war fall schaden ist an das heißt the
match award hat funktioniert aber den
restlichen sinn des kids verstehe ich
nicht außer einmal der mann stirbt nicht
passt der höhe mannes vollkommen logisch
egal nächstes geht heute nächste runde
ist noch mal das m lg kit aber diesmal
auf einer map wo man ich behaupte mal
vom lg sterben kann und wir sagen jetzt
kommt in die mitte
da könnt ihr nämlich hoch bauen jeder
auf seinem eigentum dann machen wir es
noch mal den test geissen genau 35
blöcke weg war so ok die mlg 3 nummer 23
21 water vom hals geschafft ich habe
auch geschafft beide geschafft cd-box
mich jetzt wartet wartet nein nein nein
ich bin dumm wir waren beide dumm
natürlich kann man sich ein holzschwert
kräften okay gut was machen wir schaffen
jetzt diese runde
ein bisschen order setzen diesmal nicht
so war
nein nein aber man gibt mir auch neu
kaufen können natürlich hätte in der
letzten runde einfach machen können ok
hey leute was wir haben die diamond
hasen foto pis damit kommen zeigen piece
by piece by piece phasen foto hasen foto
mit der kassen foto ok hieß es okay gut
wir können etwas vor was im ferrari
dessen pferd ja aber es heißt ferrari
erst mal 10 tobago lieb mich ferrari los
es ist immer dasselbe team jetzt die
pferde weil mich nicht lieben mich dann
einfach rechtsklick beliebt macht dir
auf einen ferrari schnell schnell
schnell
ich glaube ich oder oder täuscht mich
nur blaue lescott vom spot in andermatt
ach das ist das hier das was ist das
aber grad nein greift erinnern denn da
da hinten damit hausrat- und sattel dass
ferrari in ruhe ein versteck in der wand
mann los greifen sie auf dem feld gibt
den fährt ge auf sein pferd kämpfen aus
dem ferrari erstmals schwaiger schwaiger
töten das hat es einfach 102 das war
kann ich nicht töten
es tut mir leid ich weiß dass mir
vertraut aber da müssen wir stärke der
alte seiner homepage an
also mal vom seelischen schaden
abgesehen und er hat quasi den
startschuss gegeben
wir müssen dafür noch die hasen foto
wegschmeißen klopp hat sich jetzt davon
nicht irritieren lassen sich kurz die
hasen foto in der hand hatte übrigens
sollte wenn ihr das ihr seht war ich
gestern abend bei let's play together
mit frodo und david hain das war richtig
cool irgendwie sehr abgespeckten indie
games gespielt der exodus aus
hexenschuss oder so glaube ich mal dabei
war witzig und noch noch ein anderes
wikinger spiel mit einer wertigen frau
und risiken bossfights es war sehr
lustig wenn er irgendwann mal anschauen
könnt den vom ersten zehn
es liegt beim start ab aber ich sag mal
trifft mich schwerer weil ich im verkehr
er trifft mich gut und jetzt geht die wm
aber es wird zeit dass du stirbst kommt
jetzt durch und es dauert alter das gibt
nun die gene für die idee mit dem
ferrari so leute das war's von der
heutigen folge team oder kids ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen wenn das so ist
dann lassen wir uns vom nächsten video
wieder